I am constantly getting fundraising e-mails
from Donald Trump.
Sometimes I'll get 10 in a day.
My G mail has started redirecting them immediately
to spam.
But I still check that folder and see them
in there.
And some of these fundraising e-mails from
the Trump campaign have seemed more and more
panicked, more and more desperate.
But it turns out, based on multiple new reports,
that Donald Trump's campaign is having a financial
problem.
They have had to cut ads that they are running.
They have spent almost 75 percent of all the
money they raised this entire election cycle.
And in thinking about this, you all know that
I hate how our American politics depends on
money and depends on fundraising.
I think the system is corrupt.
I think the system is corrosive.
I think it must be changed.
It just so happens that this is the system
we have right now.
And it just so happens that this could be
a real problem for Donald Trump.
In the last couple of months before the election,
according to The New York Times, Donald Trump
has largely stopped advertising on TV.
As Joe Biden is spending more and more on
television, particularly in key states, that
could be the deciding states with the more
than 360 million dollars that Joe Biden raised
in August, which is a record.
And I'll get to that in a moment.
The New York Times goes on to say, quote,
The Trump campaign is expected to increase
television spending next week.
But several Republicans said that Bill Stepien,
Trump's campaign manager since July, was taking
a cautious approach after the former leadership
spent huge sums on television and digital
ads earlier this year to no discernible effect.
The light television spending and advertising
blackouts in some key states have mystified
allies, raising questions about how much cash
the campaign has in the bank.
Now, if you just look at the top line, you
might not be that alarmed.
For example, you might hear that Trump raised
one point one billion dollars, and that is
true.
But that goes back to the start of 2019.
And they didn't spend that money on the primary.
And that should be an advantage because Joe
Biden did have to spend money on the primary.
But somehow 73 percent of the one point, one
billion that has been raised has already been
spent.
Almost identical to Donald Trump's business
and personal lives.
They are spending on stupid things.
Going back to The New York Times, quote, The
campaign assembled a big and well-paid staff
and housed the team at a cavernous, well appointed
office in the Virginia suburbs.
Outsize legal bills were treated as campaign
costs, and more than 100 million dollars was
spent on a television advertising blitz before
the party convention.
The point when most of the electorate historically
begins to play Coke, pay close attention to
the race.
So Trump having money problems on the other
side of this.
Joe Biden is raising record amounts of money,
365 million dollars raised in August choosing
Kamala Harris caused a spike in fundraising.
And yes, Biden has saved a ton of money by
campaigning remotely for a lot of the pandemic,
being able to save up money for the TV blitz
that they are now doing.
And, you know, Trump, Donald Trump, Junior
and others like to laugh at Joe Biden's Zoome
fundraisers.
Those have been major successes.
Those Zoome fundraisers, shockingly, have
kept costs down and sometimes bring in nearly
three quarters of a million dollars in 90
minutes.
So big picture, is this shocking?
No, this is what happens when listen, we know
that Trump was using campaign funds for paying
legal bills.
We know that Trump was using campaign funds
to pay his own family.
Larra.
Trump pulling a couple hundred grand, you
know, all these different Trump kids and family
members getting paid.
And I want to remind you that there was this
idea that Trump was so wealthy, wealthy that
he would sell fund his campaign.
He wouldn't even need to fundraise because
he's a multibillionaire.
In fact, not only is he fundraising and spending
all of that money, he is now struggling to
fundraise.
And there are, of course, questions about
whether money has been used illegally.
The answer is probably yes.
In reality, it will likely have no repercussions
whatsoever.
With the last thought on this, I. I want to
go.
Back to this.
I'm not telling this because I think it's
great that we have a system where the person.
I am telling you this, because if we're going
to evaluate the campaign attached to reality,
we can't ignore that fundraising is a big
signal about voter enthusiasm.
And the fact that Donald Trump appears to
be so short on cash is not particularly good
for him.
Now, later on in the program, we're going
to look at polling today compared to polling
on this day four years ago and what I told
you two to three weeks ago about how the polling
this year compared to Hillary's polling in
August of 2016.
That has changed significantly.
And we're going to look at that next.
Remember that this program is available every
day in its long form audio format for free
on any of your favorite podcasting platforms.
If you're an I tunes gal, if you're a Spotify
bro.
If you're a Pandora kid, whatever.
Make sure you get the daily long form audio
podcast.
And let me know what you think about the state
of the campaign in your state by sending me
a tweet.
I am at Deep Hakman on Twitter
The David Pakman Show.